le 23 avril 2013 il y a 10 ans le
mariage et l'adoption devenait une
réalité pour les couples homosexuels
avec
331 voies en sa faveur le projet de loi
Taubira était définitivement adopté
alors est-ce un simple hasard du
calendrier ce weekend le centre LGBTI de
Tours à une nouvelle fois été la cible
de dégradation un quatrième incident
quelques mois on fait le point avec
Clémence d'OSC c'est dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi que le centre LGBTI de
Touraine située rue des Tanneurs a été
vandalisée la vitre de la porte est
fissurée on voit qu'il y a des marques
de tentatives d'intrusion au niveau de
la serrure c'est la quatrième
dégradation en deux mois et une pré
plainte a été déposée plusieurs élus
dont le maire de la ville de Tours ont
manifesté leur soutien à l'association
tout ça s'inscrit dans un climat quand
même global au niveau national et même
au niveau européen il y a des articles
qui démontent que depuis 10 ans et
finalement les actes lgbt-food sont en
augmentation malgré le fait qu'on est
célébrer le mariage pour tous justement
hier donc notre volonté bien sûr c'est
de continuer à être en soutien
partenaire de du Centre LGBT et de
trouver des solutions pour pour
sécuriser bien sûr le local sous le
contreplaqué les stigmates des
dégradations précédentes les autres
vitres ont été cassées en février et
mars dernier et de la nourriture avec
été projetée sur l'entrée en avril des
tentatives d'intimidation selon
l'association qui ne compte pas arrêter
ces activités on a entre guillemets la
chance de ne pas avoir blessé mais ce
sont aussi des agressions qui hésit sous
forme d'agression sur des personnes dans
la rue ça représente aussi un désir
d'aller à l'encontre des valeurs
républicaines Carmine de rien accepter
tous les citoyens toutes les citoyens
comme elles le sont lutter pour les
droits l'égalité des droits
c'est pas une valeur LGBT c'est pas une
valeur
c'est une valeur républicaine rideau de
fer alarme ou encore vidéosurveillance
des solutions de sécurisation ait été
discutées avec la ville ce lundi le
département a également annoncé son
soutien financier pour accompagner le
centre dans ces démarches